thank you for the invitation to come
here at your center and present this
effort that
we started jointly the united states and
japan together in order to promote what
we say powering the future and
internationalizing
research
today i will talk about
the world premiere initiative wpi
which is a major program of the japan
ministry of education
culture technology sports and science
and
the purpose of this
initiative the wpi initiative is to
establish an international research
environment within japan
to internationalize
the japanese university culture in other
words to advance cutting-edge
interdisciplinary research and fusion as
we call to fuse the disciplines
and at the same time
to reform the japanese university system
and change the culture within which
research is carried out and
this is
related this is concerned with criteria
for faculty hiring promotion
compensation much in the same way as it
is happening at major
u.s universities like stanford or the
university of illinois i'd like to
emphasize that the official language of
this institute is english although this
institute is located in japan
inside the ito campus of kusu university
the official language is english the
administrative staff the secretaries are
talking english there
the wpi centers
are spread throughout japan
those are right now they are 10 centers
throughout the entire japan our center
here the international
institute for carbon neutral energy
research is at kusu university which is
next to the city of fukuoka
and those centers that have been
established
are listed here those are the first six
centers that were established in 2007
and
all centers
are within
japanese major japanese universities
and each one is dedicated to a specific
specific discipline for instance
the institute for the physics and
mathematics of the universe is at the
university of tokyo
our center here is at kyusu university
there is a center at the osaka
university on immunology there is a
center dedicated in material science
which is within the national institute
of material science in chicouba so all
these centers have different mission and
different objectives
lately in the 2012
next the ministry of education science
and technology established three more
centers those centers are not as
large as the previous six centers and
they are dedicated on sleep very
interesting uh objective here they are
dedicating on the origins of life on the
earth they are dedicated on organic
molecules
and plant chemistry
so the kyusu illinois center
started in 2010 december 2010.
kusu university and the university of
illinois had a long relationship
collaborative relationship since almost
2005 within the so-called
institute of hydrogen industrial use and
storage which is the hydro genius center
this center was established at kusu
university by the ministry of economics
trade and industry methi in order to
help with
materials research on technologies that
are related with the hydrogen economy it
is
an engineering center that was
established within kusu university
specifically on materials and hydrogen
and storage
and so researchers from the university
of illinois worked in this center i
myself worked at this uh hydrogen center
and when next came in with the so-called
wpi initiative then we sat together
faculty from illinois faculty from kusu
university and we conceived this
proposal to next and in the end we
created this center for carbon neutral
energy research so it is a center that
came from a culture of collaboration
between those two universities since
almost 2005
and nowadays eisner has a wonderful
building in the new campus of kusu
university
it's
it's been delivered in january 2013
13 it's an open building it's
one roof as i say and this is the idea
to promote a new mindset a mindset of a
wpi center that involves collaboration
and we initiated the so-called eisner
co2 event we have it every afternoon it
is coffee and collaboration since we are
dealing with co2
that's why we call it coffee and
collaboration we have a nice open area
in our center there where we
we service coffee and of course we try
to promote what wpi is all about to fuse
the disciplines and get the researchers
to talk this is another view of the
eisner
building within this beautiful ito
campus of kusu university
and as i said the center was inaugurated
this this building was inaugurated on
january 29th here you can see we have a
congratulatory address by dr monterey
gardener of the us department of energy
who the u.s department of energy takes a
great interest in in our center as you
will see pretty soon because we promote
and we try to advance research that is
of interest in the
energy efficiency renewable energy
department of the doe
here we had
professor george grabtry from the argo
national laboratory delivering a keynote
address as you know professor
grabtry is
the head of
doe hub on energy storage here at argo
national laboratory
at illinois
this is
our
building the one that i've shown you and
we as i'd like to say today that we are
grateful to the government of japan
because they gave us another 20 million
dollars to develop a second building
we've been a center three-year-old and
we almost filled up the center so the
government of japan
maxed
helped us to expand and have additional
laboratory space so
eisner has expanded and it is a unit
that has a long future within kusu
university
and eisner is a center that was created
within the so-called green innovation
and sustainability
initiative of the government of japan
this is
a brief summary of
the
fourth science and technology basic plan
of japan which
is a plan
that describes the signs and research
objectives of japan for the next five
years this plan was revised after the
fukushima disaster and as you see there
are three major innovations here the
green innovation related with energy
life innovation related with the
biological sciences the quality of life
and of course
innovation of
systems societal systems industrial
systems commercial systems so that to to
to advance the economics of of the
japanese society so eisner is part of
this green innovation and sustainability
and because we are an energy institute
i'd like to introduce you first
what is the energy landscape in japan
right now and then i'm going to
introduce you to what is the structure
and the research initiatives within
eisner this is the picture of energy in
japan
predating the fukushima accident as you
see in 2007 for instance japan power was
26 nuclear and the plan was by 2030 to
be 53 percent nuclear
as you know after the fukushima accident
this is no longer the case in fact today
there is no
any nuclear reactor operating so japan
is interested in the area of energy and
in fact this is a pressing and
challenging issue so that's how
one can view eisner as a contributor to
this uh energy
problem energy challenge that japan is
facing today and in fact here this slide
summarizes the so-called energy related
concerns of japan
at the very beginning i'm trying to
describe briefly the war trends for
instance fossil fuels continue to be a
primary energy source this is a war
trend
there is an economic rise of emerging
nations in advance of economic
globalization
nuclear power continues to be a major
electricity supply
there is a war trend of introduction of
renewables for better performance
reduced cost and improved stability
there is a hidden competition about
natural resources so that those are war
trends and here there is a summary of
concerns
for instance
a major concern is direct and indirect
damage due to the earthquake
that we had
for the accident for the nuclear power
stations
there is a decreasing energy
self-sufficiency
there is an increasing trade deficit due
to soaring prices in fossil fuels and
also there is an aging and depre
decreasing populations
right japan
the projections are that the population
will be reduced by 30 percent by 2050
this will impact the energy challenge
also as as we will see so those are
major concerns of the japanese
government today
and
the energy policy now the major
i'd say framework within which japan
tries to develop its energy policy today
is
efficiency improvement and energy
conservations those are two killer
pillar points of the energy policy
facilitation of renewable renewable
energy introduction
promote clean and efficient use of
natural gas as we all know
there is now a bounty of natural gas in
the united states so if we take
advantage of this cheap natural gas and
promote power generation through natural
gas
is it's it's a step ahead in reducing
co2 emission through new more efficient
power generation cycles such as the
triple combined cycle
rebuild mid and long term greenhouse gas
emission reduction scenario
japan is always interested in playing a
leading role in the world on co2
emission reduction for instance there is
this ambitious plan 80 reduction from
the
levels by the year 2050 in fact this is
somewhat an agreement amongst the
industrialized nations such drastic
reduction so that to have a 50 percent
reduction across the globe
in other words to cut the balance
for reductions that non-industrialized
nations are willing to make and of
course japan is interested in actively
disseminated quality energy technologies
in the major southeast asia
areas and and nations in other words
japan wants to be a leader in carbon
neutral energy technologies so that to
impact the markets of asia
a few pieces of information about
how the energy
mix is in japan as you see petroleum
petroleum constitutes a major source of
primary energy supply in japan
anytime
there is a problem in the gulf
there is a problem regarding energy in
japan
when prices got increased two years ago
japan sent about 100 billion dollars
extra cash for energy primary energy
supplies so this is a serious problem
there is almost no solar almost no wind
and very small biomass so very small
use of renewables in the primary energy
sources
and this is a piece of information
japan needs about 17 hexagons of primary
energy
supply to put this into perspective
the united states needs about a hundred
and this is
the
the pie the slice of where the emissions
come from the co2 emissions as they see
here they come from power generation 46
percent
they come from the transportation sector
and of course they come from the
industrial sector so any future
attempt to reduce co2 emissions has
certainly to focus in these two areas
power generation
industrial sector and transportation
sector if we want to have this ambitions
reduction of co2 emissions
in in our center we have the so-called
energy analysis research cluster that
tries to understand
the balance in in a mixed energy
portfolio amongst the solution pathways
energy solution pathways
and the question that we had from the
very beginning is it possible to
to achieve
power generation in japan by using
renewables
and from the initial data that we have
in the initial analysis that we carried
out we may say that we can produce about
1.5 hexajoules of
energy power electricity
by using renewables if i translated it
in a percentage point
i would say that japan has a capability
of about 50 percent of its power
generation to come from renewables but
again it is not there this is just a
potential and japan has to work in that
direction
so
here is eisner as eisner we we spent our
first three years in order to analyze
this energy
landscape and see
how can we achieve
this 80 reduction of co2 emissions by
the year 2050
what are the possibilities that we have
and what is the energy mix that we can
explore
this is the parameter space as i would
say
this is of course a busy slide i can
talk about this for about one hour but i
will give you in in a few seconds the
major takeaway points
here is the energy supply central power
production hydrogen production low
carbon fuel
here is the energy use transportation
residential and commercial industrial
and over here is the concept of smart
communities
in other words distributed energy
generation
so
to to be able to slash co2 emissions
we need to focus on reduced intensity of
fossil fuels reduced carbon intensity of
fossil fuels for instance it's natural
gas as you know using natural gas you
emit
lesser amounts of co2 than using coal
for instance so
this is mixed low carbon fuel production
so reduced fossil fuel carbon intensity
using
conservation and increased energy
efficiency in in central power
production by using new concepts for
energy generation like igfc or the
so-called natural gas triple combined
cycle
and of course using
co2 capture anywhere we can have it
as you see
co2 capture and sequestration anywhere
it is produced again
low carbon
fuel usage
increase efficiency in power generation
and co2 capture this is a promising
scenario
now the energy analysis division really
talked about this is the whole picture
is eisner actively doing technical
research in each of those nodes very
good question no
okay this is as i said the parameter
space okay eisner i mean has limited
resources cannot do everything
the eisner areas are underlined
for instance advanced
heat pump advanced
lightning okay
hydrogen mixed low carbon fuel
production hydrogen hydrogen production
electrolysis
central power generation
sofc's
natural gas combine cycle so i this is
the parameter space and i snare is
targeting some aspects of this parameter
space okay of course the energy analysis
division is looking to tell us
what
has to happen what types of combinations
we need
to
to get out of here in order to achieve
this reduction and once we get this
information from the energy analysis
division then we plan to reorganize
refocus and redistribute resources
so that's that's the idea okay thank you
okay
so
again our energy analysis is reducing i
ask them give us a very aggressive
scenario where we can achieve this this
this
ambitious i'd say reduction of co2 so
here we have a 75
reduction by 2050
and as i told you in the previous slide
this can be achieved by
lowering the carbon intensity in power
generation increasing the efficiency in
the industrial sector and introducing
hydrogen in the transportation sector
so we have this information therefore in
eisner we are trying to promote the
research that will enable technologies
related with the fuel cell vehicle
it is very interesting as you see here
13 reduction of co2 will come from
demand decrease
due to demographics that we said this
this this is something that we didn't
believe at the very beginning right so
this is just a scenario right we are
exploring the scenarios
other scenarios less aggressive and so
on and so forth in order to see where we
should put resources
course
based on our initial understanding we
developed an institute roadmap what
types of technologies here are these
technologies on the top what types of
technologies we are going to pursue over
here is our research schematic clusters
and what type of research we are going
to carry out in order to address this
types of scenario again this is a busy
slide i'll pass it right now i can talk
to you later
and as i said reducing co2 emissions
can be done by attacking the
transportation sector this is the area
of using fuel cell vehicles and in order
to use a carbon neutral fuel cell
transportation sector in order to enable
one needs to produce hydrogen you can
produce hydrogen by using the so-called
artificial photosynthesis
you need issues of catalysis you need to
understand catalysis
therefore we have a thematic research
cluster on catalysis
artificial photosynthesis is a very
difficult project right now we may need
to produce hydrogen from other sources
like coal gasification for instance then
you need to sequester the co2 that you
produce
then
we need
to have transport of the hydrogen to the
refueling stations we need to understand
how we can set an infrastructure we need
to develop hydrogen compatible materials
we need the so-called next generation
fuel cells
because this is the proton exchange
membrane fuel cell technology
we need to store hydrogen on the fuel
cell and so on and so forth so this is a
scenario for the transportation sector
so having done this introduction now i'm
going to focus on eisner this is the
organizational chart of eisner as you
see
here we have the administration the
director and the director is accessed
directly by any unit within the
administration structure this is what we
wanted to do we wanted to avoid
hierarchy we wanted the director to be
accessed by any administrative unit i
would like to emphasize that there is an
external advisory committee for the
institute i will talk to this
in a little bit
we have the so-called internal programs
review committee to review all of our
programs at any instant
of time
and
our external advisory committee is made
of an international body of
distinguished scholars
the chair is professor owner adrian
he is from arizona state university
member of the national academy of
engineering deborah myers from the argo
national laboratory director of the fuel
cells
division robert finley he is with the
illinois state geological survey and he
is directing the midwest
sequestration consortium which is one of
the leading projects of the fossil
energy office of the us department of
energy and in fact they are sequestering
co2 right now in decay to illinois
they they are sequestering all co2 that
is produced by the adm companies you
know this is one of the major companies
here in the u.s of course
again we've got uh
cavanaugh from los alamos national lab
tech from tohoku university the energy
analysis this the external advisory
committee reviews the institute
and provides
advice and consultation
those are our basic research
thematic clusters divisions as we call
them as you see we have a research
cluster on catalysis we have a research
cluster in fuel cells we have a research
cluster on materials thermal science and
engineering on co2 stores
on hydrogen storage on hydrogen
production and of course on energy
analysis again there is an overlap
amongst these clusters because catalysis
for instance is involved in storage it
is involved in co2 capture is involved
in hydrogen interactions with materials
so those clusters collaborate amongst
themselves within this beautiful eisner
building that we have
we have 26
major principal investigators and as you
see it is a mix here of international
scholars
john kilner is from the imperial college
london
professor kirk heimi is from the
university of getting him
professor robertson is the dean of
engineering from the university of
wisconsin professor tuller is from
mit so it is
a mixed international
list group of people here and those in
yellow are our own principal
investigators organically grown from
within eisner those are the major key
investigators within eisner with with
international recognition who set the
research agenda again eisner is pushing
to increase the female population at
kyusu university here is
here is a list of some of our major
researchers
in eisner our percentage of female
population there is about eight
eleven percent which is which far
exceeds that
of kusu university
and uh
this is a personnel summary right now we
have about 150
researchers
both at kyusu and illinois illinois is a
satellite of the major institute at cusu
and we work essentially with postdocs
there are right now about 25 postdocs
throughout the eisner and we constantly
we interview we run
by biannual recruitment calls for
postdocs and we try to increase this
number as much as we can
now i would like to navigate you through
some of our research initiatives in
eisner as i told you one of our
initiatives is to produce hydrogen
through photocatalysis
and photocatalysis sensory light hits
a semiconducting material here and oxide
and it releases an electron this
electron is used
with water
to cause electrolysis for instance and
get hydrogen and we work on all aspects
we work on understanding devices we work
on understanding
free surfaces and we work on
understanding catalysis and as you see
our groups are
western and japanese
researchers we are we are mixed and
we are working in a concert here i would
like to mention that
we are interested in this area very much
but the roadblock is very intense here
the roadblock right now the efficiency
of photocatalysis is almost less than
0.1 percent in order to talk about
technology this number needs to be
pushed 10 percent
this is really a long-term project
perhaps it is a 2040 2050 project but we
are a research institute and we have to
pursue research
that perhaps is not
of high impact in the short term but
maybe a disruptive technology that may
come if we are successful because if we
manage to produce
hydrogen out of the sunlight then that
will solve the world energy problems
essentially this is something that we
haven't published it yet but it is
something that i would like to brag a
little bit here
the in the issue of photocatalysis the
basic problem is the charge separation
once you take an electron out of an
oxide here the oxide is potassium
tendulate
once you take the electron the purpose
is to be able to take this electron and
cause it to to form current the issue is
the problem the traditional problem is
that this electron tries to recombine go
back to its hole and therefore you don't
have a current here this is a wonderful
collaboration
between kusu university illinois
university researchers and imperial
college
we are talking about
internationalization of research the
experiment was done at kusu the
numerical simulation was done at
illinois and kilner studied what happens
with the first layer of the tandalum
atoms there so what they developed they
developed the so-called mechanical
sweets in other words they allow the
electron to move into this
semi into this organic layer a film
layer that they put above the tenderloin
but at the same time once it passes it
cannot return so this is called the
sweets that they managed to do they are
working now and publishing this this
wonderful piece of work
we are working trying to use
photovoltaics to push the hydrogen
efficiencies higher
here is one of my colleagues professor
adazi who as you see
managed to increase this photo electron
conversion coefficient from four one
percent to seven percent
if we get this to be ten percent then we
again we talk about technology
and this is what eisner has done you see
you have a concentrated research grant
a
recess grant that is characterized by
longevity and then you manage its year
to increase your efficiencies there
and a spin-off of what we are doing is
energy conservation by
working on organic leds
and here again professor adazi managed
to push quantum
electroluminescence
efficiency to almost above 20
in this paper appeared in nature in 2020
by working with between the singlet and
triplet excited states in order to
minimize the energy gap by design
and of course as i told you from the
very beginning we have roadmaps in the
institute how this
division is working so for instance we
were thinking that by the end of 2020 we
will get efficiency 70 7
we've already achieved this efficiency
when photovoltaics
quantum efficiency 80
we are now at 20
so this is good progress within the
institute
there is a wonderful division also on
catalytic material transformations
this is professor olga's group he works
with professor rouse at illinois they
are both world-renowned experts on
catalysis there is a wonderfully nice
competition amongst themselves the kusu
illinois competition but they are
working together and
what we managed to achieve so far is to
mimic biology in activating hydrogen
again we need when we have a fuel cell
we need
to have catalysis in order to get the
proton out of the molecular hydrogen
and in order to do that we need to
activate hydrogen and here the
activation is mimicking biology what
professor
olga managed to do he designed a
synthetic analog of the active side of
a natural hydrogenase so he analyzed
biochemists in his lab analyzed how
hydrogenous activates hydrogen and he
designed a synthetic analog of this
of this activation and this is a paper
that appeared in science in fact this
year now professor ogo is telling me
that he managed to have this achievement
here 2013.
by mid 2020s
he tells me that he will get this
synthetic analog to be robust
and in order to be ready for technology
so again we are taking a 10 year span
here but that's how it takes to go from
the lab to technology
here now
is is my area
as
professor dasser told you i am in the
area of materials i'm working
within eisner to understand
what
is
the way by which hydrogen degrades the
mechanical properties of materials
one of the issues is hydrogen
accelerated fatigue fatigue
of materials is the failure of materials
that we get if the loading gets repeated
cyclic loading and what happens is that
what hydrogen does
it accelerates
the
way by material fatigues this is if we
call a measure of fatigue this is
an in the absence of hydrogen this is
load cycling loading as increases the
damage caused by fatigue is accelerated
in the absence of hydrogen but here is
what hydrogen does
it further accelerates that fatigue and
we found out by putting a little bit a
few ppms of high of oxygen within the
hydrogen mix then we find out that this
onset of hydrogen-induced acceleration
is pushed to higher and higher loads so
in other words we found out that we can
mitigate this hydrogen-induced
acceleration
by
by putting just a few ppms of oxygen in
the mixture
we have a co2 capture and utilization
division we want to capture co2 as i
told you this is something that we need
to take into consideration if we are to
reduce co2 emissions we are doing
research here that is
is addressing fundamental issues related
with co2 captures that will enable
sequestration
and
we also work in the conversion of co2
into a useful product
for instance the concept is as follows
we have renewable energy this renewable
energy can be fed into an
electrochemical device and this
electrochemical device it can get and
reduce co2 into co
and that co can be used for instance as
a syngas as a town gas or can be used in
order to produce methanol for instance a
fuel we can take co2 and turn it into a
fuel
and of course to do that you need
catalysis and here again another
wonderful collaboration between illinois
and chusu they developed a catalyst
the so-called pbi catalyst by which they
they are telling me they managed to us
to achieve
the largers the largest
current the largest efficiency in
transforming co2 into co and this
appeared on the cover of the advanced
energy materials this year
at the same time this technology has
been used for the fuel cell catalysis
and again professor
nakasima at kyusu university and paul
kennedy at illinois they managed to
devise the most
durable electrode for for fuel cells
that we have today they are telling me
based on carbon nanotubes
we are working on sequestration as i
told you we are interested if we
sequester
co2 underneath the ocean if it leaks
what happens to monitor co2
i think i went ahead one slide this is
the next slide so this is a slide that
shows
how we can understand the behavior of
co2 when is sequester underneath the
subside in the earth here is a numerical
simulation and here is experiments of
co2 supercritical co2 that is pushed
inside the porous material these are
experiments are carried out at illinois
those are carried out at kusu we want to
understand the interactions of co2 with
the liquid brine and of course the
porous structure of the material
here we want to monitor if there is
leakage of co2 this is a project where
we participate national environmental
research council of uk where
artificially they inserted co2 under the
subside and the kusu university
researchers professor sitasima
measured the distribution of co2 just
two meters above the seafloor and about
50 50 centimeters above the ocean floor
of the ocean surface monitoring
technologies in other words research for
monitoring technologies
uh since i'm talking about eisner let me
allow me to brag a little bit we got the
sumiya award this year the sumiya award
is given to material scientists who come
from two continents on research projects
on two continents here we have three
continents professor tuller at mit
professor kilner at imperial and
professor isihara at kyusu university
this has happened because of eisner
eisner brought the three continents
together at kyusu university
our students also receive awards i i'm
very pleased to report this slide here
we won
the boe toyota mercedes
and rail award
about
designing a hydrogen distribution
network in the northeastern united
states this is the northeastern united
states and the chusu team our team
won the first award
we are trying to internationalize our
environment we are working with the
sandia national laboratories the
livermore valley open campus which is
about one hour east of here
the laboratories and national
laboratories are opening up for the
international community so in other
words they moved the fence so that
people can go there without passports
and dr sommerday
a research scientist of this laboratory
is is the leader is the lead pi of our
hydrogen structural materials division
this is an unprecedented i think
development a united states
laboratory is working with japanese
research institute and in fact a
scientist from the u.s national
laboratory is leading a research
thematic cluster in japan
and i would say we are everywhere we are
collaborating with the entire world
as you see here both in europe and the
united states
and
we are trying to
to reach out
with the society we try to bring
eisner
to take a
i mean in in the radar of the energy
state holders we organize the symposium
at tokyo on
the japan u.s energy collaboration and
as you see here our ambassador john
roose addressed the symposium here and
he emphasized how important is to bring
the younger generations of japan and u.s
to talk to one another
and as director of eisner
i cannot overemphasize how important is
the younger generations to begin talking
to one another i think this is the key
i believe this is
a fundamental a key concept for any
change
that that may happen in the scientific
exchange and collaboration between the
two countries it is the younger
generation needs to be educated
differently today and hopefully eisner
is doing that we are working closely
with the us department of energy the
fuel cells technology program we get
advice
from this program in fact we are
grateful to this program because it
helped us somewhat see where
the relevance of our research
can be located and identified
and we have we we are ambitious we have
many initiatives in mind for instance we
want to bring postdocs here and in fact
usually the concept of a postdoc is a
positive is attached to a professor and
works with a specific professor here we
want to have a free postdoc a postdoc
that will go around see the institute he
wants to work at project a wants to work
at project b
this somewhat
brings down the barriers amongst the
faculty this is something that
definitely we want to do and of course
we are seeding new projects based on the
information that we get from the energy
analysis division we try to seed we try
to explore new projects
our idea is that 10 of our projects must
fail if you don't fail means you don't
try to do what we call something that
can be disruptive so failure is good in
fact one of my one of our members of our
external advisory committee kevin odd
has said
tell your scientists in the laboratory
that
if they don't show failure means that
they are not working on an impactful
projects and this is something this is a
message that i always try to to pass
across of course this is a bit difficult
in japan it is much easier here in the
us but this is the the philosophy by
which we are working and of course again
our internal programs review committee
is some is a committee i'd like to say
that keeps us
focused keeps us
to have a healthy research portfolio and
with that i thank you for your
attention this is my last slide we
brought
our libraries together it is very
interesting how the librarians are
interested in exploring new concepts of
librarianship across the pacific to
bring information how the information
can be brought to researchers at kusu
university for instance information from
illinois or vice versa in fact now they
are on their own they are working
kusu librarians are visited illinois and
back and forth they are creating various
portals so that kusu researchers can
just with with a stroke and access the
illinois resources and vice versa i
enjoy meeting meeting with them the
librarians as you know are the most
important people when when it comes to
high quality research unless you have a
good library you can you cannot do good
research so i'm very excited that the
librarians are working with us
and
with that i thank you very much for your
attention thank you
so thank you very much for your
presentation we were both in tokyo last
week
because i've been on the program
committee for the wpi program since 2007
since the beginning it's really
wonderful to see how eisner has
you know just taken off and already
started to blossom i want people to
understand the scale
this is a
basically minimum 10 million dollar a
year grant for 10 years
with a possible five-year extension
after that
so we're talking about 100 million
dollars of government money that's
flowing into this in addition eisner is
bringing in money from other sources now
that's right that's right eisner
eisner leverages this money from from
the government in order to expand its
portfolio in fact eisner if i recall
well
i mean
participates at the percentage of about
14 15 of the chuseo university research
funding
is through eisner it it shows how how
big the pie has become it is not only
the 10 to 15 million dollars it is it is
bigger than that it is all in fact it is
almost twice as much yeah yes and so
sure enough i think what you listed 230
or 240 published papers last year alone
i mean something yes on that
neighborhood um so
this is a major effort
um
i'm curious
how do i keep my microphone um
so if there's one thing you'd like to
see more of in the program what would it
be
that's a
very nice question okay
i think i think
this stage of our program
we are we just started
what what i would like to have is to
become more focused one aspect is is to
become more focused in other words i'm
waiting for our energy analysis division
to to somewhat identify
perhaps
five
solution energy solution pathways and
then redirect our resources
so somewhat we started ad hoc
at this point we say artificial
photosynthesis disruptive technology
let's pursue it or materials under
severe environments is something that
the us is interested and is pursuing let
us pursue it
also at eisner so we started by by by
doing what is out there now if we get
more focus and redirect our resources i
think will make the our center more
efficient and uh and so they're going to
do this analysis really based on
economic impact as well as on the
technology itself the science impact
that's right that's right and and and
the the the point is that these energy
analysis is within eisner they talk
every day with the researchers they talk
with professor isihara and they ask me
they ask him where is your catalysis now
how do you activate hydration what are
the perspectives here is it in five
years is it in ten years what do you
think so there is a very close contact
amongst these the researchers and the
analysts okay i would say excellent
let's open the floor
go ahead
and
myself of california office
so it's a fantastic widespread research
and
really
looking forward to the result so i'd
like to know 10 years from now
what could we see
how many achievements you are expecting
in 10 years
very nice question i can enumerate a few
achievements that i want okay first
let's start from my area
i think if we develop a hydrogen
resistant steel
and we can tell the public look
this is the steel this is
the solution we solve this problem
i think this will be something that
it is in fact impactful we are not there
yet
but we are working on that we try to
identify mitigation strategies by
working on the basic science
so
we have i i believe we have the finest
team in the world at houston university
right now specifically on this problem
right so this is something sophisticated
alloys that can be
safe and reliable so 10 years down the
road if we do this not only japan will
benefit the entire world the united
states will benefit out of this
if we push artificial photosynthesis
beyond this
roadblock right the roadblock is 0.1
if we come up with something disruptive
there and go away from this one
i think that that will be something that
that will be i wouldn't say this point
disruptive but very encouraging that
basic research is impactful that we are
doing
if we activate hydrogen right in a
robust way
and lasting way
this will be very impactful also and
let me
brag a little bit professor ogo who is
one of my wonderful colleagues that i
have there is telling me petrus i will
do it
so hopefully we will do it because i
trust him that he will do it
so here are three technologies that we
may impact in the future in in in a very
serious way in a very serious way
i should open that to other people in
the audience
this is not really my area so
you know we have the pre-court energy
institute at stanford and there are
various uh centers related to that the
tomcat energy
uh research initiative inside that so
there's a lot of work going on at
stanford do you know the group the solid
solid oxide fuel cells all right
professor prince's work first his work
is one of the finest
very distinguished i mean faculty
working on
cutting edge
areas yeah
go ahead yeah i have a i have a new
question
uh
so
i was amazed by the by the work you did
to
to push the fusion of different
technology to
bring new ideas
uh i'm wondering uh how what what do you
need to really
incentivize the scientists and the
people in the center
to
to make the fusion happen i mean like
you did a lot to bring different to
bring experts scientists from different
fields together and exchange their ideas
i think that's specific facilitation
uh so what do you what what do you do to
incentivize them to
to do the fusion of technology okay the
easiest way to do that is if you have
money
you see
money money helps right
yeah
and so
the the nice thing is the structure of
the wpi is such that
mext wants the director to be a powerful
figure in the institute
the director to be in charge of how
resources are distributed so
being vested without authority of course
i always consult with the associate
directors and the science steering
committee of the institute right
we can channel resources where we need
so we say researcher a and researcher b
if you work together you will have this
money or give us a proposal give us a
proposal on what you can do together and
we will get you money and that's what
happens right so we got the numerical
analysts at illinois to use the blue
waters at illinois petascale machine
right with
the group of professors
at kusu university who does the
experiments we got them to talk and we
funded this effort internally and that
i mean
prospered so
so that's the easy way to go right
through money the other way the most
difficult way i believe is to get the
people to talk to each other right
this is not as easy this requires
i think
built up of trust
built up that
our value can be added in in a
prospective collaboration and this is
not easy for people to see
especially if they come from foreign
cultures
and and i believe this is
one of the key elements of the wpi
program to get those two foreign
cultures to talk
i'm trying as as much as i can i'm
trying by getting coffee together with
scientists by drinking beer together by
going to dinner together those are
cultural i would say do you have many
instances where you'll see a proposal
and say you should add someone from
this different specialization yes yes we
do we do yes we say
i always get that any proposal i get i
pass it to the internal programs review
commit in order to get an advice from
them and for instance sometimes they
identify another faculty for instance in
this case that i talked to the illinois
and the accused faculty they identified
professor kilner from the imperial
college and professor kilner uses this
lease as we call right low energy ion
spectroscopy to check where the atoms
just the first layer of atoms right in
this
thunderlade potassium thunderlade where
and he used least technology in order to
identify yes indeed tandalum atoms are
there and participate in these sweets so
we brought the imperial college because
i was told that
you've got one of the best in this area
bring him in
i think that your question's really
interesting because even in the u.s
university it's really hard to get over
the walls between fields we've done a
lot of this with the research centers at
stanford that do bring together money
and and distribute to people in
different disciplines
japan was
much more severely siloed than the us
was
and this is the biggest change that i
think i've seen in japanese universities
in the last 30 years
easily
i have a question this is a very huge
project so i think a commitment of
government is very important and also uh
investment from the private sector is
also very important how am i going to
get
money from my investment
from a private sector ah this is this is
a very interesting
we were we were talking about this with
professor dasser just an hour ago
yes
now
we are
as i say a mission-oriented institute we
are an institute that
tries to drive
research that will impact engineering
so we try
to come in contact with the industrial
sector and tell them that they will they
will get value out of us
so up to this point this effort is is
done by individual researchers
we we haven't done it in a way that is
systematic at the institute level
so this is a project that we are working
and we need to work in fact this is a
project this is a project
a relationship that we need to establish
it is vital as we have been advised by
the wpi program committee for instance
right now we are doing it on on on
individual research basis we are not
doing it
at the institution level but it is very
important
yeah
so i'm interested in research strategy
and i'm interested in your example where
you said you'd like to focus maybe in
five key areas so
i'm just asking hypothetically um
let's say those fires get defined by
some process
what happens to the researchers
how do i mean do you go out and find new
researchers and
other researchers are
left to go somewhere else or well
the the area the the issue here is
that
researchers have to either to redirect
or they will uh
move right that's that's very important
and in fact this is the entire notion of
the wpi that this will be a robust
organization and
once
it identifies the areas that needs to
move forward has to redistribute the
resources
this is this is a paradigm shift in the
japanese university culture
that
we
we move based on the objectives and the
productivity
rather than
the classical system in which
faculty work on their own i think one of
the interesting things about your center
is the international connections
because you see if you're moving on the
world scale
that is a very good possibility that you
may move into something that is an
extension of what you've been doing
somewhere else
really one country is probably not
sufficient scale to have people move
around successfully previous programs in
japan would have a fixed limit of five
years or ten years and at the end of the
five years you'd have some very gifted
people who are suddenly stuck
with no place to go in their careers
so i do think the international
nature of the center feeds this well
precisely yes
and and also keep in mind in our culture
here in the u.s for instance right in
our major research centers
right usually it is healthy for a center
to have a 10 turnaround
right annually
so
in fact the satellite institute at
illinois at the satellite institute this
is happening
we receive new projects
and about 10 of the faculty they have to
to redefine themselves right so
now we try to do that in japan as well
good
uh could you say something about
co2 sequestration uh i saw a talk at the
usgs a while ago
how about i call it a hard problem yes
yes i can't quite tell whether it's
going to work
this was a combination of science and
economics
a very hard problem yes indeed
especially for japan
right
in japan the co2 is considered seriously
because as i told you japan really is
interested in slashing co2 emissions in
fact play a key and leading role in the
world
so co2 is in their radar co2
sequestration so there is already one
side at the northern japan in the island
of hokkaido
thoma kumai that has been chosen as an
experimental site where they will
sequester co2
while they have hydrogen production it
will be called gasification for hydrogen
production at the same time the co2 will
be sequestered so it will start pretty
soon as an experimental program so they
want to do it i mean it is it is
something that they consider
as a country japan needs to pursue it so
we thought eisner
should participate in this in this
effort through fundamental science and
from what my fluid mechanisms are
telling me this is a wonderful problem
for fluid mechanics it is a three-phase
flow porous media brine
supercritical co2 this is an area that
hasn't been investigated difficult area
so
for as far as basic science is concerned
is a wonderful area to to expand
and at the same time hopefully we will
be useful in telling
the real world right what are the best
aspects of sequestration for instance is
it trapping is it
dissolution is it mineralization at the
end
so basic science issues
as far as we are concerned as far as
japan is concerned again to close
is is is of interest to the japanese
government to pursue that
yes again it is difficult problem yes
indeed
we've politicized it here right it's
kind of one of those energy problems
that's become sort of associated with
political
boundaries i'm not sure what's happening
in the u.s here i mean we are pursuing
this type yeah there are there are four
projects i think in the us that are
pursued are pursue right now for
instance i know they wanted illinois the
midwestern project they they were
already pumping co2 okay underground
underground water yes in fact they have
two wells there they have two wells
about uh
two kilometers
deep one is the one that is pumping it
down and the other is uh equipped with
monitors
see what what see what's happening yes
and it goes really really down very
almost uh
we sequestered it in co2 in brine that
was there three million years ago
still is that okay so it is a very safe
place at illinois whether they are doing
it okay okay good another question co2
in the brine
it really is it's a nasty acid for the
steel and so
when you get when you get the hydrogen
problem solved you can work on the co2
problem
remember this is an institute that goes
in fact it's a permanent institute that
uses university as far as the president
arikau of kusu university is concerned
that's what that's what he says
he kusu university will take over after
the wpi program expand uh expires
so
causing earthquakes by disrupting that
yes and you have plenty of those already
yes yes that's that's a serious problem
and again an interesting basic science
problem right
yes
that's it is
so that's why we said let's work on
on converting co2 right into useful
product
other questions
if not we've got some refreshments
outside and we're delighted that you
would come here this afternoon despite
all the trouble with traffic and so
forth and please join me one more time
professor safronis thank you very much
you